[Music]
all right Faith welcome back
how are you glad to be like
um going through a whole lot
but trying to get through it what's
going on I see that you're pregnant
yeah I've sh it was a tragedy I wasn't
supposed to be afraid I just had a baby
and I had breakfast with my arm but it
wasn't 100 like
it it wasn't 100 supposed to work
and I guess that was like the 99 chance
you're on birth control but you still
got pregnant yes
and who's the father it's the same guy I
had my last everybody my parents you can
how do you feel about that
I feel the same like I feel stupid
like damn
some a person I'm trying to get away
from all of a sudden I have to know two
two people I have that we both love that
I love so much
involved with him a person that's done
so much to me cruelty
and sick how it is like he didn't want
the baby at all
he said that's too much
abortion is still legal in California
too far along oh you didn't realize and
I love his baby no matter what if it's
not it's not the baby's fault
at all when you discover you were
pregnant
I just found out like about like two
months ago
when I started getting big I don't know
we're like
how far along are you I'm six months
pregnant six months
so he doesn't want the baby
no it was a choice of either I stay with
him and allow him to
kill the baby himself or
leave
and I had to leave before I left
and it's not it's hard as hell out here
especially being pregnant
are you still working the streets no
out of respectful for hopefully my son
because this is your second child right
it's my fourth fourth
where are your other three
um once with her dad is with my my he's
the one who's like
she she was low-key like you know
provided
of me before I had to turn like you know
18.
but
I had like ran away
and left with him
but he said she didn't take care of my
daughter ever since
and other ones with the guy just left
I have to go back for her
do you see your kids still
yes I do yeah
yeah that's why it hurts for them not to
be um
and especially me being pregnant now
it makes me realize how much I need the
more than they they more than they leave
me
foreign you kids are all young right
yeah my oldest is six
the oldest is six yes
I had a very young out damned if she was
ever like grow up and
and have to go through like you know
what I went through or be like you know
curious of it
I should be here walking proof instead
of her like
trying to
look for something that is here I can't
give her a love of a man back into her a
love of a mother
and tell her what a man can do I wish I
would have knew that I would have never
like even
wanted love from one
so bad I would have knew what they can
do how can I get short destroy a person
like how I am now
you feel like you're taking steps
backwards
I'm confused it seems like I'm doing
like I seem like I'm doing the right
thing by leaving him
but it just seems like it just got
harder
be hard for you to support your family
especially being pregnant by myself like
and me being a woman by myself
with no defense
is that I'm vulnerable
it's like I have to hide myself
because they they men are like Predators
women that like that is like you know at
the lowest point like me
and I'm
I'm hurt I'm alive
I'm losing toys I don't know
what's wrong was right
what are you going through emotionally
now
yep
she's cute
a lot of it
I
I should have been there a long time ago
maybe it would be way much easier
I wouldn't have had to
and I wouldn't have to be out here
like I am
how do you know
20 you're 20.
with four kids
I have my first day when I was 13.
well I was talking about 39 14. my
second baby I got pregnant when I was
17.
and I had her when I was turning 18.
my
um my third I just had her
um January 14th
and now
another one so soon all in one year it
just didn't make sense
how many fathers
three three are any of the fathers
raising the kids or in their lives only
one well it's
starting to but
it's I'm wondering like
it didn't count
he's only doing it because he has to
but I'm not gonna leave my baby you know
with him I'm gonna get all my kids back
that's why my step forward is to leave
him so I can leave life
you don't get away from him you'll be
back on the street
I'm gonna shoot out now just I'm like
you know on the streets working working
as I'm saying if you go back to him
you'll be working yes
what's your biggest fear
Diane
and Marcus well my big experience my
kids like it would be happening to my
kids
like
my kids my everything let me devastating
experience really hurt any type of way
and for them to be gone like you know
all the way
how much of an education do you have
um I wasn't able to actually graduate
I didn't even graduate the 11th grade
I was supposed to graduate like
I I had I had maybe
216 so it cut my credits to make a
singer you know after graduate earlier
but I still couldn't even do that
I was distracted a lot I feel like I
wanted you know
I want to you know go back to school
and actually become somebody
you have any kind of support at all
family anything
um
the only family I have is my but I don't
like to put her in my business
I feel like if she knew
like was actually going on and what she
sees and things is going on
she was a little bit different
but I don't want her to know that
the other side of me
tell me about your mom again
hmm
about the selfish person I can say that
she says he loves me but doesn't show it
she shows me more like
more jealousy than anything
she she loves a man right before she
left me but of course
I wasn't the first priority I know that
she sees somebody that I would never
become never ever will be she would
never ever grow up she's gonna always
gonna be that same person still to this
day she's still the same person selfish
and she's very sick I could say that
especially I
I hate that I have to go through it
and that's why I'm trying my best not to
put my kids through it
our drugs is part of your life
I could say
I don't do that as much as I did
when I feel like I'm falling asleep in
the streets
I don't know I do
because I don't want to fall asleep I
don't trust people I don't trust like
you know
I'm not in the place where I'm by myself
and like you know like close doors like
you know it's just mine I can just close
my door so you're on the streets right
now
yes
until I find another place like
that I can afford
guys it's hot it's very high out here
even used to rent a room with somebody
yeah you're in one of the most expensive
parts of the country
man if I would have known that I wish I
would have been fluent
but it's too late now
one day I will move I don't like I don't
want to be out here in La no more
I don't want to raise my kids to be a
part of
the property that goes on out here and
the violence yeah the violence in South
Central is reason enough to believe
trust and believe just
they don't have to be a part of it they
just seen it just you know just crossing
the street or just you know out the
window
that's devastating enough
I want to be able to give him a better
you know a better life
in a better you know setting to have a
better life
instead of
them they're saying something to be
coming in
I want to change everything
and this that first step is changing me
I know God has a plan for me
sure I'm sorry I know I know that God
has a plan for me
I know he loves me a lot because that's
all I have really
especially when he comes out here
to these streets
it's only God that's keeping me here
it's making me stronger
as I say that it's it's even more
sympathy and well it's even more
sympathy but it helps me
give my guard up more
to fight back instead of not fighting
that
it's making me a stronger woman I can
say that
wish you all the luck in the world
you're gonna need it
thank you
if I don't believe in that I believe in
blessings
thank you very much